[Music]
hello and welcome back to the road to mm
as always my name is Caleb dumb be and I
am your driver on this journey today I
wanted to take a look back at some
chef's history and go over some games
from the one and only Bobby Fischer so
why don't we see what made Bobby Fischer
Bobby Fischer so some of you might be
familiar you know these players all have
all the famous players have you know
there are a mortal game or there's some
fancy name named for some of their best
games Bobby Fischer is has actually
played a game that's been deemed the
game of the century so probably not this
century but they were talking about the
1900s Bobby Fischer played the game of
the century and I thought what better
game to start off on looking at some
games from his career than than this one
and so this is a game Bobby played when
he was quite young against Donald Byrne
who was a very strong master at the time
and Bobby Fischer actually had blacks
and they flip it around here and the
game started off Knight f3 Knight f6 c4
g6 and we see that after d4 castles
black has adopted a King's Indian setup
he's simply V&K dode brought the knight
out and got castle early on white now
has a couple options he can go into the
Kings Indian defense with this movie 4
or he can just play a little bit more
quietly
efore i would say is is kind of the most
principled testing way to play right
your opponent didn't take the center so
so you grab the center completely the
downside to this is of course you're
making some weaknesses along the way and
after a move like d6 and c5 or e 5 black
is fighting for the dark squares and
that's just kind of the Kings Indian
defense in the game white shows Bishop
f4 which is a slightly less you know
aggressive option I would say it's
grabbing this a 5 square but it's
allowing black to now make a claim in
the center with d5
now that efore hasn't been played d5 is
in fact possible and we transpose into
some lines of the green felt actually
yeah these two openings share a lot in
common
the difference is really whether or not
black puts this pawn on d5 or leaves
this pawn back on on d6 and so in this
case black grab the center with d5 and
White's response was Queen b3 and this
is kind of transposing into some some
more popular lines where I think Queen B
3 has played a move earlier in the green
felled actually black simply captures
yeah of course the d5 pawn under some
pressure so black removes the pressure
by taking on c4 and now after Queen
takes c4 black plays c6 and white does
in fact grab the center so so this still
isn't going to be transposing into the
Kings Indian defense here that should
kind of sailed when when black played d5
but white is still making a very strong
claim in the center now with with E 4 so
this is a pretty striking position we
often think like the ideal setup for for
one player is kind of this with the
Knights in the center the bishops coming
to the center and the central pollen
dulo so what does black have in exchange
for it here what why would Bobby play
like this why would he give his opponent
such a strong center exactly
so yeah what would those breaks be how
is black actually going to challenge the
center it's not super clear to see
usually when we seen opening like this
where white has grabbed the center and
black hasn't black usually is playing
for some pawn break something to free
its position whether you know in this
case there's a few ways to kind of
attack these funds like c5 would attack
the d4 pawn ie five would challenge
these centers and f5 would challenge the
e4 pawn but looking at these three moves
none of them really seem plausible here
it's really tough to achieve any of
those those pawn breaks so I like some
of what you're saying I like getting
this Bishop out to g4 I'm not super
convinced about this East six move yeah
well you're just you're giving up
important squares whenever you push
these pawns forward you give up
important squares and so the main idea I
want to get across here this is a pretty
interesting line because black isn't
exactly trying to challenge the center
using a pawn break like c5 or e5 or f5
instead yes
he's using his pieces to challenge the
center as opposed to his pawns and so
we'll see how Bobby manages to you know
quite expertly maneuver his pieces
around to put a lot of pressure onto
this black center so yeah onto the white
center so black actually starts with
Knight bd7
developing this Knight up first
rook d1 black does continue with Knight
b6 forcing this Queen onto a slightly
less pleasant Square Queens c5 is played
and now simply Bishop g4 from black just
getting his piece developed and as you
said putting pressure on this night in
turn puts pressure on the central d4
upon by removing a defender we saw now
Bishop g5 from white and what do you
think of this move
what's the idea and is it a good idea
okay so you're thinking you put the
bishop out of the way for an eventual f4
is that we're saying yeah so so this is
the the rule that I've stated before in
these classes Bishop g5 breaks an
opening principle right you're not
supposed to move the same piece over and
over again until you're fully developed
and you get castled and so it's it's
quite often when it's best to break one
of these opening principles right you
know the best move has to ignore some
principle but the the fact is you have
to be very certain that you're breaking
the principle for a good reason you're
making a significant threat you're
causing a significant problem or you're
somehow improving your position which
you have to do right away otherwise it's
always just going to be best to follow
opening principles finish development
get castled and that's exactly what
whites should have done here is just
finished development and getting castled
the idea with Bishop g5 as I see it was
just to put pressure on this e 7 pond
make it so this night couldn't really go
anywhere couldn't really pressure this
Center because eventually you know if
this Knight moves there's always going
to be ideas of this pond hanging even
taiks with the bishop is sometimes gonna
be a problem and this was White's idea
well I mean sometimes you can but you
just have to be certain you have to be
certain when you play move like Bishop
g5 and I don't know if white thought
that he was certain but he shouldn't
have been because Bobby came up with a
very nice move here to prove to prove
White's mistake so I'll let you guys try
and find a tactical line here that
really shows why whites play has been
incorrect and this is a killer move so
if you haven't seen the game before
don't feel bad if you can't find this
one because it's pretty unnatural ya
know there's there's some crazy tactics
by by Bobby here so yeah we're looking
at this Queen which seems a little bit
overextended and that's where a lot of
tactics come from is pieces that are
loose or kind of over advanced
overextended and can easily be attacks
so which pieces look a little bit loose
to your eyes here we've talked about the
Queen any other pieces or pawns or
squares
what else sticks out besides just this
Queen that might be a little bit
susceptible well okay that's an
interesting idea
so even looking without tactics we do
have this option Bishop takes f3g takes
f3 forcing this G pawn on to f3 and you
mentioned this idea of wears white gonna
Castle after G takes f 3 but you think
King e2 so well that that's that's the
thing here is this is a very common idea
for white in the green field actually
playing this move Bishop takes f3 even
while the Queen is still on d1 might
well very often want to capture back the
F pawn because it supports the center
and it allows for ideas like f4 f5 to
come through a lot more quickly and the
fact is how is black ever going to use
this G file it's a little bit unclear
alright so Bishop takes f3 usually isn't
the best idea in a lot of Greenfeld
positions now sometimes it is that's
true
so the actual idea revolves around the
loose pieces so that's what I was
talking about earlier this this Queen on
c5 is a loose piece I asked to try to
find some other loose pieces and one
good way to do that is to look for
pieces that have the same number of
attackers as defenders so this piece is
attacked one time and it's also defended
once so if something happens to that
defender or if another attacker is added
somehow then this pawn could be captured
so I would qualify this pawn as a loose
piece I would actually qualify this
Bishop as a loose piece it doesn't
perfectly fit the definition its
defended right now twice and attacks no
times but things can happen to these to
these attackers right these defenders
that's exactly right and that's the move
that was played is Knight a f4 so what
happens on Knight takes a four Knight
takes me four yeah what if simply let's
say Queen B 4 for example what happens
on on this move
how do we get our piece back
so things get a little bit crazy yeah so
Knight takes bishop is a good idea
because now there's Bishop takes d1 and
White has a lot of problems here what
drove you away from this idea of Bishop
takes Knight though this looks a little
bit more natural well then you can take
this bishop but no why does something
else here I think to look out for let's
look at the bishop yeah and now all of a
sudden things are getting a little bit
more complicated this queen can step out
of the way and after you takes now this
night is attacks well that that's that's
always ways away from happening but yet
there is this Knight takes g5 move that
I think would be quite good for black
and this isn't actually specific lino I
looked at before the lecture but I think
Bishop takes you and or even Queen d5
there's a lot of moves here that I think
are gonna be good for black just because
this white King is a little bit isolated
so night take say for isn't gonna work
for white and white realize this so
simply queen a3 and now after night
takes c3 we see pawn takes c3 and so at
first glance this looks like we've
helped white alright we've we've
strengthened his centre now this d4 pawn
is more or less unassailable but so yeah
you want to play Knight takes e4 here
right so you this is a very good idea
but if you want to play Knight takes e4
what do you have to calculate what's the
problem so yeah I'm sorry what would
happen so okay so if Knight takes e4
we're worried about Bishop takes these
seven so so let's try to calculate so
Knight takes e4 Bishop takes a seven
what can black play in this case whoa
whoa whoa so it's not quite pinned yet
this is legal so you got to be very
careful but yeah let's just put it on
the board what could happen here
Queen oh yeah well the thing to look out
for here is Queen e8 is a reasonable
reasonable move and I think blacks
should have to move the Queen but white
isn't forced to capture you know this is
a common mistake that happens in a lot
of the you know lines that players
calculate where they're like okay this
should take c7 he wants to take my rook
no matter what I do he's gonna take my
rook but in this case I think you're
giving white a chance to actually just
develop and so Bishop e2 might come on
the board and now I don't know if white
is actually doing so poorly you can
simply get castle soon and this rook is
a little bit stuck on on f8 yes that's
that's the problem well let's stay
focused our Queens attacked what do we
want to do with it yeah so you should
get that out of the way d5 is an
interesting square I'm not sure it's
it's the best square you you're not
really creating any any extra threats
threats
so you always want to find harmony with
your pieces right so you're looking at
this Bishop which is threatening to take
off this night which is defending the
dark squares you're looking at this
knight on e4 which is attacking the dark
squares and you're looking at this
Bishop which is attacking the dark
squares so what black wants to do is try
and coordinate with this pieces these
pieces to create some some very specific
threats so he's actually staying on the
dark squares here and he plays Queen b6
which doesn't immediately make any
threats but it is you know keeping an
eye on some weak points in and the white
can't and so you can imagine that you
know obviously white can't push this
pawn but if anything ever happens to the
c3 pawn and then this d4 pawn is looking
weak and the c3 pawn is already under
threat you can imagine things like c5
might bust open this diagonal as well so
what I'm trying to say is you want to
use your pieces to work together this is
how you can use active pieces and turn
that activity into real threats
you can play things like Queen d5 and
this is a very nice central square for
the Queen it's by no means a bad move
but it's not yeah so try and let me
finish my points and then we can talk
about it but so Queen d5 as I saying so
it's centralized it's an active square
for the Queen but it's not really in
harmony with with the rest of your
pieces still puts pressure on undie 4
but it's not really you know adding in
these extra threats of getting in on
these dark squares so you want to be
looking at your other pieces to see
where you're actually trying to aim and
that's how you can use activity to make
general threats or real threats so we
see Queen b6 so first of all what
happens if this ship takes f8 what's
going on here
anything special or should we just take
back and sit on the position
yeah I mean you can try and make
immediate threats like this but the
thing is your position is already so
good that you don't need to be doing
this this extra fancy stuff if you just
take this Bishop back even after Queen
b3 and rook e8 even if these Queens come
off the board you're up so much time and
you have so many weaknesses to look at
that
you're already just going to be
completely winning for example if you if
you try to get out of you know this
discovered threats Knight takes c3 is
simply hitting this Bishop twice you can
play like rook d2 but and I'm just kind
of playing moves here things like Bishop
b4 I'm gonna say I already look to just
be winning the game
you can't castle so I'll take the bishop
and if this work ever moves out of the
way I have discovered attacks and any of
these moves and white is simply lost and
if you don't get out of the discovered
threat if you try to defend this pawn or
something
there's simply Knight g3 and this work
on h1 will will fall so you don't have
to do anything fancy if Bishop takes f8
and so white comes up with a better try
and that's Bishop c4 finally trying to
get developed we see Knight takes c3
from black the idea being if Queen takes
c3 well I'll ask you what is the idea
it's not too complicated how do we get
the piece back
yeah you just pin the bishop right and
this bishop can't move there's no good
way to defend it and if you do to do
defend it I'll just attack it again and
you'll get the piece back so Queen takes
c3 not going to be an option and white
comes up with this move Bishop c5 and so
now it looks like you know we've removed
this Bishop from this threat of being
pins we're hitting this knight we're
hitting this Queen so what can what was
blacks idea how is black going to
continue here sure you can start with a
check but he'll move out of the way
let's say King f1
you have two problems to solve it's not
so easy to solve both of them
so there's a rule in chess that I've
heard before where it's when your pieces
threatens and you have a few options
sometimes you can defend the piece for
example this this knives detect if we
had some way to defend it then that
wouldn't be a problem anymore you can
move the piece out of the way
remove the piece from from threat so
example our queen is attacked you can
move it out of the way or you can make a
bigger threats so that's the that's the
third thing that makes chess really
complicated is what is a bigger threat
ninety five is an interesting idea
this isn't one that that came to my mind
but let's take a look at it see what's
going on so you were saying if Bishop
takes b5 Queen takes b5 and Black's got
control over these these light squares
and I'll agree that that does look like
trouble so let's see if we can come up
with a better way for white to play here
any ideas
it's not super easy but white's queen is
attacked so why should probably solve
this problem the move that comes to my
mind is something simple this is just
queen d3 and that piece would still be
attacked so 95 is an interesting idea
fisher has something better here and i
think white would actually be doing
pretty well in that position we just saw
so i'll give you the first move rikiei
check you were correct is is the way the
black started here and white does play
king f1 and now what could blacks idea
possibly be here
come on everybody loves to throw away
their queen especially when it's not
your queen and somebody else's of course
black's idea is to simply play Bishop e6
sacrificing the Queen and this is a
pretty incredible idea
from from Bobby here so if Bishop takes
Queen and this is what was played in the
game and we'll take a look at the
continuation after that maybe what Byrne
missed was what happens on Queen takes
c3 seems like a very natural way for for
white to play simply take the free piece
but what does what does black have here
what well I mean black could move the
Queen out of the way but he's going to
be down a piece yeah so what does black
have how do you take the piece back I
can find this one it has to do with what
we were talking about right way back
here we put this Queen on b6 because we
wanted to make more threats on the dark
squares so since black is organized as
pieces in this way to at for everything
so that everything is fighting for the
dark squares he's a very nice tactic in
this position here after Queen takes c3
it's all about the dark squares so Jacob
Tarlow in the Twitter and the YouTube
chat has found the answer simply Queen
takes c5 and there is a nasty pin on the
Queen white can recapture but let's see
what's going on here after Bishop takes
Bishop takes rook takes this is going to
be a very very pleasant endgame for
black although looking at it it feels
like there might have been something
more for for black in this position but
maybe it is just just Queen Queen takes
c5
yeah that this will definitely do the
trick
especially because White's King is
blocking a his rook from getting into
the game quite so quickly yeah so Queen
takes c3 looks like the most natural
option but it's simply not really
possible so then my next question what
happens on Bishop takes a six black
can't recapture because the Queen will
fall
so what's the intermezzo here what's the
in-between move for black to save the
queen yeah you just give a check and now
this King is actually running quite
short on squares in fact you might have
seen this pattern before yeah so Bishop
takes c6 not going to be playable so
white is really left with no other
option but to accept the sacrifice and
he takes black's queen of course black
now continues with Bishop takes c4 check
King G 1 but now white is left in the
unfortunate circumstance where his king
is kind of entirely trapped so are any
of you familiar with the idea of the
windmill the windmill in chess yeah so
this is kind of a version of the
windmill so black could simply take this
rook on d1 and try to play for
compensation here which he would have
plenty of for the Queen but instead
there's this move ninety to check which
is very nasty because after King f1 and
Knight takes d4 the black king or the
white king rather gets caught in this
sort of cycle where no matter what
happens he can't really escape well I
can do anything he wants kind of
obviously Fischer didn't waste all that
time he simply comes back to e2 back to
c3 and now actually captures the bishop
instead of the rook this hits the Queen
the Queen comes to b4 and now rook a4 is
a very nice move
saving all of the pieces all of the
pieces are somehow tied together the
Queen takes on b6 and now black captures
on d1 and at the end of the day one
night - one night one rook - one rook
and then two bishops and a rook for a
queen along with you know this this
devastating looking looking King on g1
well yeah what Black's not even thinking
about past ponds here Black's thinking I
what's what's the best way for me to
kill the guy and that's exactly what
happens in the game h3 was White's
choice trying to give the king of flight
square rook takes a to King age two and
now Knight takes f2 and this King is
looking more and more in danger rook e1
was White's choice black simply trades
and after a check in Bishop f8 Knight
takes we see Bishop d5 the pieces are
starting to organize themselves against
this King Knight f3 was White's choice
94 Queen b8 the queen is trying to
defend but after b5 h4 h5 King g7 and
after King to g1 I'm sure you all see
the checkmate in 9 maybe I think
checkmate in 9 it's very very nice
Bishop c5 check King f1 Knight g3 check
King II one Bishop b4 and the King has
walked to the Queen side and eventually
stuck yeah this was a classical
classical chess game and Bobby Fischer
just demolished him
and so this was named the game of the
century in Bobby Fischer's career it was
very very early on in his career like I
said he was pretty young I don't
remember his exact age but he was an
up-and-comer and this game where he just
absolutely destroyed Donald Byrne was
was definitely one to look out for so
this I think is one of the most notable
games and in his career early on one of
his most famous games I do have two
other games here to talk about but
before I get to that any questions on
this game it's a very tactical game
where Bobby really was just sacrificing
I had every turn after this one early on
mistake by a burn where he played Bishop
g5 once again
it's tempting sometimes to violate
opening principles but unless you have a
very good reason for doing so it's going
to come back to bite you
so simply Bishop e2 and castles would
have been better for white Bishop g5
just you know it doesn't feel right and
it wasn't so a very nice game from Bobby
okay well let's move on do you want to
see a game from his famous World
Championship match or a game from his
famous US Championship where he went
11 and OH undefeated I actually don't
remember this was around 3 we'll start
we'll start with this one because it's
pretty interesting
Spassky started with d4 c4 and after
Knight f3 and Bobby Fischer shocked the
world and played c5 of course what
opening is this does anybody know it's
the Benoni
so Bobby Fischer had never played the
Benoni in his life and of course it
doesn't have the best reputation as far
as chess openings go yeah that was
exactly his thinking and the Pannonia
was a surprise indeed for Spassky I'm
sure he had no idea this was coming and
hadn't done a whole lot of work in it
considering Bobby had literally I don't
think ever played it in his life so
Spassky simply grabs the center takes
takes d6
these are the main moves asbestos he
chooses this line with Knight d2 he
simply wants to step off of this
diagonal before moving this epon not
allowing Bishop g4 and things like that
Knight also a very common outpost for it
as on c4 Knight bd7 from black II four
from Spassky Bishop g7 Bishop e2
castles castles black brings us rook to
e8 and so far this has been very very
very much the mainline stuff and now
Spassky plays Queen c2 which isn't you
know like the absolute most popular move
but it's definitely been tried a lot
before it's not an uncommon move
and so after Queen c2 let's take a look
for black here and see what's going on
what sticks out to you what are some
plans and ideas for black and let me
actually flip the board so we see it
from Bobby's Bobby's point of view
because we want to be winners
so the b6 square actually isn't the
square this knights looking for yeah uh
uh f8 either you know these aren't great
squares for blacks pieces once again
you're trying to find some some harmony
from b6 you're not really looking at
anything from f8 you're not really
looking at anything either so e5 is a
square you can come to but it's it's
kind of tempting faith there
what's the night lands on e5 it's a
matter of time until f4 comes in and
forces this night away so developing
this night out it's going to be a little
bit of a problem for black and this is a
big reason why the benoni
is a little bit troublesome is because
black simply has one too many pieces in
the Benoni right you can't have all of
these pieces get developed they're just
simply aren't enough squares for them to
be on good on good squares so a common
idea for black is to gain more space
somehow so where can it gain more space
certainly not in the center probably not
on the Kings side because that's what
white wants to be doing so yes on the
Queen side
yeah so a six and nb5 are very common
ideas in the game however bobby shocked
everyone came up with a very unique idea
and played Knight h5 so what sticks out
about this move this move should be kind
of sending up some some red flags so na
let's what's the most natural response
for white let's just deal with natural
moves here yeah Bishop takes Knight and
what what like what what is black doing
right that's that what that would be my
thoughts if I had the white pieces here
Ceaser opening up the G file but but
look at his pawns I mean this is just
ridiculous right yeah I guess so so what
is what is blacks compensation
you mentioned the G file so if you can
make use of the G file that counts as
compensation somehow but sigh yeah this
this square yeah so
yeah that's that's part of the important
thing here when you're looking for
compensation it's good to notice the
structural things and that can happen
right like this G file is now open I
have some compensation for for the
structure right now due to the structure
my rope can get to the G file but you
also have to look at this the pieces
specifically you mentioned the d4 square
so yes we might be able to put a bishop
on this G Force on this d4 square and
that would be a very nice place for it
you mentioned the Queen and it's true
that we might be able to come out to
this age for square to make some threats
what about this night working this night
go to make threats on the Kings side I
mean through the e5 but it's not really
to the Kings side yet there's a more
important square than me 5 u 5 as a
stepping stone for it for black here
yeah so you can go to f6 or or 5 but
those are both squares stepping stones
rather to get to the g4 square this is
where black actually wants to be this is
where you're gonna be making these
threats against once again the dark
squares in the white camp it's all about
finding this this harmony with your
pieces so the knight could come to g4
the bishop can come to G can come to d4
the couldn't come to h4 and you can see
he's making threats along the dark
squares and so this was Bobby Fischer's
idea this this pawn cements this g4
square and that's what he's going to use
to launch his attack simply Knight c4
from Spassky a very natural move hits
the d6 pawn oh so yeah I do want to
mention so Bishop takes h5 was actually
played in in the game and it's true that
maybe actually
Spassky could have just ignored this
Knight and then this move looks a little
bit less you know sensible you know if
you if you just ignore this night and
like you said the knight on on the rim
doesn't always in
that's my catchphrase that I'm gonna
gonna come out with four nights on the
rim doesn't always impress it's much
less catchy than the other ones
grim dim whatever you want to say but
yes so this night doesn't make the most
sense over here blacks idea was probably
that he wanted to free up this F pawn
and try and challenge White's Center a
little bit but maybe it's not Anna
actually the best way for for black to
play but especially acceptance accepted
the challenge captured this night on age
five said prove to me that you have
enough compensation so after night C for
Bobbie went about doing just that with
95 to start with this night comes back
to III looking at some of the newly made
weaknesses in the black camp of course
the spawn coming to age five doesn't
only weaken the punch the pawns
themselves but also weakens important
squares like f5 and f6 we see now Queen
h4 from Bobby it continues pulling
forward making more threats sure it is
defending this age Punk keeping the the
White Queen out of the game Knight g4
Bobby continues just following up on
this attack and all of a sudden what are
you gonna do about h2 what are you gonna
do is a very relevant question to be
asking and Spassky decided I better
actually just take that guy and after
pawn takes g4 like pawns have kind of
been fixed right
due to these last few moves where Bobby
managed to make a checkmating threat on
the Kings side white felt the need to
fix blacks pawns
why didn't why play this move h3 trying
to maintain this structural deficiency
for for black
so what was stopping like Bishop e5
actually looks pretty interesting I
think maybe the problem is f4 hits the
sky but then there's Bishop default but
then maybe I can just take this guy well
yeah we take take you are threatening to
go g3 yeah no this looks pretty pretty
interesting I might have to actually
sacrifice my piece back to deal with
these threats it's not really ideal for
me so maybe this would be a significant
problem for white the thing I was
looking at and I haven't checked this
with him engineer anything I was I was
thinking you know what if black just
steps back and then all of a sudden
there's still a lot to be proven here
for white if you don't do anything I'm
going to capture this H pawn and if you
do something about it I might even have
sacrificing ideas like Knight f3 still
Bishop takes f3 and stuff like Knight f3
to follow and this G file is is going to
become relevant producer
so what I just wanted to say is h3 is a
very very weakening move even if there
isn't some immediate tactical knockout
which there might be after Bishop e5
I haven't calculated that all the way if
black just placed simply you've made a
permanent weakness this is a something
that black can latch onto to rip open
the Kings side so yes white captures on
g4 keeping these pawns untouched there's
a rule in chess actually where if you're
being attacked on one side of the board
you don't really want to touch your
pawns there because every pawn move that
you make is going to create weaknesses
going to create further inroads for the
opponent so continue attacking see
Bishop f4 Queen back to f6 having to
defend this pawn simply g3 from white
and white probably felt that this was a
necessary concession if you place
something like Bishop g3 black is going
to come at you very quickly with h5 and
H for play something like Bishop Queen
d2 rather maybe this is something you
can try but still I think black is going
to be advancing up the board quite quite
quickly things like this what will come
as well
move that bishop behind there what are
you what are you saying to me well
that's just a one move threat right this
is not something huge the black has to
worry about you just move the Queen out
of the way
OS but yeah I mean if the pawn lands on
each port
well if you commit everything over to
here you still have problems to worry
about in the center and on the Queen's
side well I mean there's many ways to
lose a chess game right you can get
checkmated or you can lose all of your
sentence and then still end up with some
problems so g3 was what's White's choice
he wanted to keep this Queen defending
this eforp on looking at ideas of b5 and
B for possibly kicking this Knight out
of the way
so Bishop d7 was aimed at controlling b5
pushing this forward so white responds
with a for trying to keep it under wraps
but at this point black actually just
has a very very pleasant position
position here this bishops is on a nice
open diagonal this pawn is actually
feeling quite weak for the white player
and flex play on the Queen side is kind
of going to be inevitable pawn on g4
actually does a nice job of hampering
all of White's plans oh I just press the
0 instead of the next arrow so we will
have to find it once again so a four and
then black plays a very very nice move
here
b6 so why was b6 played how does this
make any sense so it stops 85 but why is
a5 important to stop you know why not
just rip the eight here
or even just a six why not
rip be it or a six well it's all about
you know finding blacks plan so I've
mentioned it a couple times but but what
does blacks plan here what does he want
to do yeah it's a lot about this
diagonal this is part of blacks plan is
how can you we can loosen up this
diagonal a little bit find something to
target on it
so yes starting well the actual pushing
of the b-pawn is the plan right we want
to push this beep on up to be four and
now once this night we'll have to go
away you can imagine if before this
night has to move now we actually have
kind of free reign over this diagonal to
make threats on the b2 pond as well as
activate our rooks along some open files
so a5 is a huge problem for black here
because now if you ever play b5 I'm
going to capture this and you have no
chance of playing b4 anymore so black
plays the slow approach here because
he's in no rush and plays b6 so now the
idea is after rook e1 you can play this
move a six and now against a5 you always
have this move b5 in response and that's
exactly what Bobby was planning so white
doesn't play a5 rather rookie - and now
b5 Bobby just continues with the natural
plan so why didn't Bobby play d4 right
away this was the plan so
so what are some ideas for it for white
here it helps to look at his past two
moves he's kind of telegraphing his idea
sure yeah then I could simply move out
of the way but that's not really a
reason to not play b4 I think what he
was worried about was this move e5 and
this is why a white actually took the
time to line up all of his pieces here
so we could take this but after Bishop
takes so it being kind of a complex line
to try and figure out on the fly
you would get this pawn back but sire
Lee sure what would be going on in this
position this actually looks like it
might be quite good for black still but
Bobby I don't think wanted to allow
these kind of yeah at the end of the day
black is gonna have to bishops interrupt
for the Queen which should just be
winning if you take back with the Queen
this pawn might be hanging there's also
this idea of Queen Queen d6 and you're a
little bit pinned up so I don't know
maybe e5 is an idea that white was her
Black was concerned about and then maybe
Knight e4 I think this is the point so
this is a common idea in games that I've
actually I think I talked about a game
with daro spirits last week or maybe a
couple weeks ago where he did a similar
thing right you push a pawn forward in
the center and it frees up a square for
your pieces and denies your opponent
other other pieces that are that are
active so if black recaptures this pawn
now after Knight e4 and for example just
removing this Bishop back to c1 this
bishops going to be cut off in this
Knights on a very nice square and I
think this is why Bobby didn't didn't
allow this
so clingy six instead just keeps things
simple and after b3 simply Ricky seven
and like threatens to double up white
makes a threat to the b-pawn black
simply defends it not yet committing the
b4 takes takes b4 from white sea floor
from black and in the end there's just
too much pressure on this this epon and
Bobby advances slowly ends up trading
off this Bishop for this night winning
this pawn and he goes on to win this
game with the white king running into
some some danger in this opposite
colored Bishop end game and after Bishop
d3 Boris actually resigned and so this
was the big turnaround game of the World
Championship for Bobby up till this
point you know he he had lost one game
and lost the other one by forfeit so
Spassky was actually doing quite quite
well up until this point but this is
where it all started to go wrong for
Spassky and started to go well for
Fischer and quickly before the end of
the lecture I don't have time to go
through this entire game but I do want
to pull up the critical moment here
Bobby you played very well and and Benko
did some suspect things in the opening
but this game is famous for oh I just
showed it oh well pretend you didn't see
so there's a key tactic in this game
here that Bobby ended up using to to win
the game so I wanted to introduce this
position this of course is the US
Championship where Bobby Fischer went 11
and 0 and 0 no drawers no losses 11 wins
a feat that has not been repeated in
history and this was one of those those
key wins against pal Benko chess legend
yeah that's a great idea
yeah you're doing a ton of stuff at the
same time and the problem is what a
black plays f5 this is the problem queen
is attacked you don't have time to take
on the Sun if you trade Queens I'll take
back with the night or even with the
rook and take your night so f5 is the
big problem so if you guys have been
following the lectures for a while I do
have a favorite way to prevent moves if
you if your opponent has a move that you
really really just don't like the best
way to stop it is just to make it
illegal so that they answer this tactic
since we're running short on time I'll
just give it well closed you don't put
the rook on f5 you put the rook on f6
and now this pawn isn't going anywhere
and if black captures the rook now we
play e5 you still cannot play f5
well ringtone go enough and mate would
be unstoppable in the game we saw King
g8 from black trying to hold on for a
little bit longer but it just wasn't
meant to be and Bobby won this game
pretty pretty easily so I wanted to show
that yeah I wanted to show that tactic
before the end of the class because I
thought it was a very nice one and it
kind of rounds out a few of a few big
moments from Bobby Fischer's career of
course the up-and-comer who wins the
game of the century early on this world
championship match
when he defeats Boris Spassky in game 3
the turnaround a moment and then this
game was also very very nice part of his
11 and OH streak in the US Championship
so bobby fischer of course one of
everybody's favorite players one of the
best players of all time and I thought
it'd be nice to introduce some of his
games
so any questions about the lecture
overall any
any final thoughts that stick out - yeah
definitely Bobby Fischer went one of the
all-time greats even getting a standing
ovation from his opponent at some point
well I think that's about it for me
thank you guys for joining me on this
week's lecture of course this has been
the road to 2000 and I will see you all
again next week
[Music]
you